and it gets even more interesting chris
because
there are reports now the teams that
we're talking to tom brady under the
impression
he wants to reunite with a guy he played
one game with right last year in new
england antonio brown
i don't know that bruce arians is going
to want antonio brown because he was
with brown for two years in pittsburgh
he knows what goes on behind the scenes
but uh you know is
he i don't know why brady would want him
either when you've got mike evans and
chris godwin and oj howard and cameron
braid who i think is going to and joe
and ira kaufman of joe buck's fan agrees
cameron braid is going to have a
resurgence in this office yeah that's
right do you really think it makes sense
to push for an unpopular figure like
antonio brown to go to tampa and join
forces with tom brady well yeah they
certainly don't need him is there risk
there as we know yes i mean we don't
even know where he stands with the
league yet um if i think there's one
coaching staff or head coach that could
make all that work in that quarterback
who could you know keep a and a b on the
straight and narrow and focused on the
things that are important damn i do
think it's bruce arians and tom brady
you know anything i know about i mean
antonio brown from everything i know was
living in tom brady's house and there
there was a real relationship there
where i think tom brady you know sees a
lot of good in antonio brown probably
you know he recognizes there's some
issues there but i think he sees a lot
of the good and i had heard that a
little that you know that conversation
came up with different teams during free
agency now we don't know if he pitched
that with tampa because like you said
they're pretty stacked i mean hey
you know godwin evans their top five
statistical receivers in football evans
is a superstar a super super superstar
and godwin is really really good on the
verge of super stardom so yeah that
might be too many people to feed and
just too much personality and that could
cause issues in the wide receiver room
to where i don't think it happens with
the tampa bay buccaneers maybe one of
those other teams that could have
happened but not the bucks
yeah i'll tell you i i uh i'm fascinated
by the possibility but you're right the
nfl hasn't decided what to do with
antonio brown and uh
he's got several different issues that
can keep him out of the league for half
of the season or longer and i think the
nfl's got bigger fish to fry right now
than to worry about antonio brown and
i'm surprised tom brady if it's true
would be advocating for a team to sign
antonio brown but i think when he gets
to tampa he's going to realize i don't
need antonio brown i've got a great slew
of weapons here
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports